and one thing a white girl could do to
just blew my mind he could put her hair
behind her ear Oh
[Music]
optional areas comment I'm so lucky to
have here you guys gonna love them
please give it up for the dog forever
[Music]
story about me drowning you know yes I
drowned that literally drowned and you
know and it's like wow that's amazing
you being so large and buoyant how would
you drown well it was it was when I was
smaller you can believe it I was younger
I was a kid I was in this day camp at
this.look take care well you know
there's my mom it was free
so she put me in the daycare we up there
with these little stupid-ass kids and
like we was like 11 and 12 so he used to
beat him up and take the peanut butter
jelly sandwich you know and I counseled
her she was you know she smoked weed she
was a she was a whore you know she was
nasty and she didn't know what to do it
is we have no arts and crafts or nothing
can't do with us we just found out
plans making up our own games man you
know catch me you can finger me you know
and that got hold out the one they ran
out of hand soap so that what that one
gonna be a fun night you know you know
you know this this day camp was in a you
know predominantly you know suburb may I
say you know like it isn't here more
whites and blacks you know it and I was
living you know when I got around white
people a lot of things that was
different life you have season passes a
six flags and they could go a bunch of
time but the main thing was the white
girl that do me for a loop I've never
seen a white girl before I had never
seen nobody named Rebecca or Samantha
Elizabeth I was around the pieces and
charandas no I'm saying you know
Chiquita you know that was my girls and
when I seen Elizabeth man oh my god she
was cute she had her hair and her cheese
was like Rosie like a cartoon like
Charlie Brown who you know the Charlie
Brown girl he had a crush on Maximus day
your cheeks was red and one thing a
white girl could do to just blew my mind
he could put her hair behind her ear oh
my god that was so sickening to me I was
like holy
do that again Elizabeth she's like what
are you talking about oh man I break out
the coast where I could I was in love
with her from that day all I followed
her everywhere
please behind your ears from me just for
the day Lavelle I'm sick of doing this
ray my neighborhood me she was it had a
crush on me but she's mad cuz I like
Elizabeth they can turn someone you like
first of all watch your damn mouth
around my wife woman all right you being
highly disrespectful second knowledge
Jesus can you put your hand behind your
ear huh please yeah yeah I can see
trying to pop out you try again it
popped out sancai no more time
for you all right
she said let me get some hair off
that I ain't got no time if you can't do
it on your own you don't need to do it
at all so you know one day we was at day
camp and we was trying to we were
supposed to go to uh you know go do
something with the counseling she
couldn't find out nothing to do but you
want to see your boyfriend I heard on
the phone talk to him to come over
Robert I'm gonna see if I can get away
i'ma bring the kids over and let him go
swimming I swim you know I couldn't swim
I'm back we all swim
we don't black kids don't swim we'd
learn later after were my friends that
we learn how to swim and we this is
black swimmin we were three three feet
we walk it on a wall look at me I'm
swimming player we're gonna put our foot
on the moon I'll get in there
there's a black pool bodies on we don't
go in the deep we did we jump off
the diving board close to the side and
get out somebody try to put your bitch I
you up if you push me again stop
playing I just got my hair done we we
don't we don't swim but I wanted to go
she said hey guys I'm gonna take you
over to my apartment complex but you
can't tell anybody where we're going cuz
you want opposed to take us away from
you know the daycare center we put infos
leave the premises but she doing some
file she said we went over there
she didn't watch she watched us for five
minutes we were unsupervised all these
11 12 years old all by herself and it
was cool cuz I was trying to get up on
best anyway so you know we jump in the
water I had on my little Aquaman swims
show us they tired up a little tight up
in my crotch and I'm ready to get out
there and file the bell for round the
pool she was cool knowing we were you
know three feet but Beth was trying to
get away from me apparently she was in
me as I thought you us but I was like
what's wrong Bell come on baby
slow down put your hair behind that's
talk you know and she kept gonna leave
me alone and she just started floating
and I'm filing her you know and I'm
mesmerized by a beauty you know just the
hair behind our ears just have me hip
hypnotized and I'm I'm fouling it all
the way I know that I wasn't paying
attention I'm still walking running
water but the water over my damn nose
but I kept walking with her next thing
you know she took off like a feather
just floating across the water cuz she
white they know how to swim - swim real
well like a damn mermaid and I went
under the damn water I just know what
I'm gonna water blue bum this is weird
I ain't slowing like that fine know what
I can do to get in front in the water
like Bevin man this is weird because I
don't know why I can't breathe now and I
didn't know what to do I was trying to
get up but I couldn't get up I couldn't
get up next he know I disappeared in my
mind I was gone and all I dreamed about
white women just leaving me all over the
place and when I woke up I'm laying on
the side of the pool the camp counselor
she freaking out like oh
I'm losing my job me hell
we make
she didn't care if I was alive or not
she worried about her doctor she went
even there's you know they're probably
doing some ungodly with her
boyfriend smelling like marijuana and
the paramedics trying to give me
mouth-to-mouth with that woke me up cuz
you even put your lips on me I don't
know you
I came through and I threw up - they
said I was unconscious for 10 minutes I
was dead I died and I'm sitting there
like them I died and best wish better
best thinking ass head went home with
her parents they had sent everybody home
and she left me that dirty bitch after
that I didn't like white girls never
again I went back to shaquiesha
education I don't care you can't put
your hair behind your ears can you swim
swimming you gonna be my boo for
life
[Applause]
[Music]